Hi everyone, I'm Sam from the FreeWings flight school
and today I'll be going through the topic of flight practice with you.
Flight practice — and what we set up here, whether outside or in the classroom,
doesn't quite all fit together yet.
What we do is first build up our own knowledge.
And we have to — or rather, we should — do that with solid theory.
Once we know the theory, we can apply it well.
And once we've trained the application, we get into the realm of being able to do it.
And only along that path does it really work.
We're aiming for 100% correct answers.
For all of this, when looking at flight practice,
it helps to picture the whole thing in the context of a real flight.
Speaking of which,
it actually starts at home.
A flight is something you have to prepare for.
It's usually not a good idea to head straight to the launch site
without having done your homework beforehand.
Then you get surprised by something at the launch.
And if you've already
thought through at home what you actually want to do,
it makes things much, much easier.
And the first thing that belongs to that
is asking yourself: am I actually fit to fly?
That means knowing what kind of shape I'm in,
whether I'm mentally clear, whether I had any kind of bender
the night before and have a hangover.
Am I fit, have I taken any medication
because maybe I have some pain
I'm trying to suppress?
It's all different from what I expected.
What I'm getting at is: I have to know
what a front is, and I have to know
what foehn is.
And if one of these three weather topics shows up,
my ears need to perk up and I have to ask: what's actually going on?
Because, as I know, a front — and also foehn especially —
usually brings a lot of wind with it.
Strong wind is always pretty bad for paragliding,
because we're flying relatively slowly.
Foehn in general is a dangerous situation,
where as a student you don't go up in the air.
Later, when you're very experienced,
there are geographical spots
where you can fly even in foehn,
but you need a lot of prior knowledge for that.
Same thing for thunderstorms,
where you need a lot of experience.
Generally, with thunder clouds and front clouds,
these are situations you mostly don't want to be in.
Then it's important
that you've also looked into the regulatory side.
There are paragliding maps
that show us the legal situation.
And there are airspace restrictions,
which can be pretty harsh if you don't know about them.
And for airspace restrictions,
to stay informed,
you have to check, every single flying day,
the daily NOTAMs
to see if any current airspace restrictions are in place.
Some of these can be quite large,
like for example the World Economic Forum in Davos,
where the airspace gets very heavily restricted.
And I can imagine
that there too,
if you fly in,
you'd get an escort pretty quickly
from much bigger aircraft.
So as a paraglider
it's not exactly clever
to fly in there.
But there are also smaller restrictions.
We have a meeting,
for example at a regional event site,
it's full of people,
and there's a cylinder
where it's also forbidden
to fly over,
because it's very big,
with a gathering of people.
This information you'll find
described pretty well in the NOTAMs.
And then you also have to think about
where you want
to fly — for example on a cross-country flight.
Then military flight operations
are important — military aviation services —
and you need to know about them,
because depending on the case,
you might be able to fly higher,
since the military
— on a weekend
is calmer
than, for example, during the week.
Another part of all of this
is checking your gear,
making sure
that the gear
you've got with you
works.
That includes, for example,
charging the battery.
It's no use
if you end up in an emergency
and your phone has died,
then you can't share anything,
because in such a case
we can really —
since we have the restriction
of many being in the same context —
all of that
we can use continuously,
and it helps,
for instance, with talking.
There's also a feeding task,
and so on in front of the preparation,
where we restrict ourselves.
While packing up — if you somehow landed in muck and the wing sat in the trunk of the car for a week,
where it's warm.
Those are all things that later shorten the life of the material and aren't good for the wing.
And when you unpack,
(unclear)
if it's not what you were expecting, you think about it.
Also important — take provisions with you, make sure you've got enough to drink.
Drinking is essential.
Drinking, drinking, you've got to be a super drinker.
Drinking — drinking — going along with that, of course,
for example with a urinal condom,
where you can also urinate in the air.
And for women there are diapers too.
And you can get the problem under control.
But it's not smart to skip drinking because of the problem.
Drinking is really important.
It helps with concentration.
It keeps you fit.
And at the end of the flying day
a nasty headache can come up,
which you can get if you've had too little to drink.
Then, once you've done all the preparations,
it makes sense to drive to the flying area
and have a quick look at the landing site.
We were at the landing site,
and quite obviously,
because you have relatively little altitude,
you start looking for it.
And then it's good if you already know it.
That means scouting out the landing site
really does make sense.
We can already check
where there are public obstacles,
such as cables,
that run nearby, across the valley.
Where there's, say, a big tree
you might need to watch out for.
And how we want to land at all
is something to look at in detail.
There are good aids for that.
Namely, mostly the local pilots,
who know how the landing pattern goes.
Cricket — sorry, the wing area.
The standard pattern is a left-hand pattern.
But depending on conditions
at the landing site, it can vary
and be a right-hand pattern instead.
Depending on wind conditions.
That's usually well marked
at the landing site,
clearly visible.
If not,
ask the locals.
Also important
is that you know
where you'll actually be flying.
We do a bit of flight planning.
When you're at the landing site,
we can check
where the launch site is,
usually.
And where there might be an emergency landing field.
If the landing site were closed,
it could be
that something has happened
and they're picking up an injured hiker.
As I mentioned,
the rescue helicopter lands right on the landing field.
It's important
that you know
where you'd land.
And then there are other things
we have to think about,
regarding turbulence,
say there are big
trees there,
that can cause turbulence,
in moderate wind,
which could surprise us
and disturb the landing.
Doing all these mental preparations
makes the flight
much, much easier overall,
because you've got a plan B in your head,
and having a plan B is already very important.
We never go on a new flight
without knowing
what we'll do
if it doesn't go
the way we thought,
always have preparation lined up
for the what-ifs.
On top of that comes
the consideration
regarding wildlife.
Wildlife protection
is a big topic.
In the past we'd always
go into the debate
where today we say
the paraglider flight
passing through the wildlife
— a new study suggests
(and now it comes at a cost),
shows actually
the opposite,
that the paraglider pilot
does carry some responsibility,
has to take wildlife into account,
and it's really important
to pay attention.
We have a site
where local wildlife information
is usually on the info board
described, mostly at the lift station,
where, for example, areas
that we shouldn't fly over at all
are listed.
But it's also important
to have a basic idea
about wildlife in general.
And in the theory
we know for this topic,
there are also lots
of questions about wildlife protection.
It's about, for example,
the issue of
when animals have
their young,
since exactly during that time —
namely in spring
and in spring
we have beautiful flying.
That means
we end up at those places
where, for example, eagles,
chamois and ibex
raise their young.
For eagles,
you have to expect, from March
through May,
that they're sitting on the nest
and also defending their territory.
For chamois it's in May,
and for ibex
it's in June.
And during that time,
if the animals are there,
fly away.
It's simply fair
toward the animals,
that you don't say something like
"it's safe to stay,"
or "the thermal is"
particularly good,"
"I don't care"
if there are three chamois below,
but instead — fly away.
The animals already
have enough stress
from all the environmental pressure,
so on top of that
paragliding pilots
who claim to love nature
shouldn't add to the stress.
As already mentioned,
the local specifics
of individual wildlife sanctuaries,
are mostly clearly readable
and posted at the stations.
And here too:
ask
— not just look,
but ask local people,
they're always happy to share.
When you get to the mountain,
right to the launch site,
it's like this for many,
that there's already a bit
of butterflies in your stomach.
Having a few butterflies
is actually a good sign,
because it means you're taking things seriously.
And especially when
you don't know a launch site,
for example a tricky flight,
going to a launch
you don't know at all,
it's all the more important
to have a guiding principle there,
which is reported there,
to apply
and so on,
at every launch site.
It must always be
possible,
ideally until liftoff,
to abort the launch.
If we launch from a cliff
edge,
where you've only got a little run-up
and then it drops off into a big void,
that's definitely not the abort phase,
and it's also
not the right launch site.
Naturally, depending
on the pilot,
the boundary shifts a bit.
But the guiding rule
applies to everyone, always.
Then of course we have
different criteria
for the launch site.
When we arrive,
we first have to
figure out what kind of wind we have at home base.
If we naturally
have downwind,
meaning tailwind,
at the launch,
we definitely need
the kind of launch site
where you can run
for a long way.
Meaning:
behind us is clear,
we can't have to weave between
and run through.
Instead we check
that the area
behind us is free,
so we can accelerate
and at takeoff
still carry speed,
and that behind us is clear.
And it's good
when we find the launch site
in a state
where there's a slight updraft,
the situation looks naturally different.
Then we can do a beautiful
wing in the row
and a reverse launch.
And then we can
start with
a wing with strong sail,
the wing builders
running into it,
uphill into the slope.
That means
we have to make sure
that behind us,
or also toward the wing,
there are no obstacles,
so we don't stumble.
The same applies
with tailwind:
if we have
a bit of tailwind,
then maybe we'll need to
pull the wing up against the wind
and then a small arc
and run in the fall line.
And then ideally
there should be no obstacles.
And that's an important
criterion for the launch site.
Also part of that is people gathering,
especially at a public launch site
where the lift drops people off,
you get lots of spectators very quickly,
the spectators are on one hand
nice,
watching our sport,
looking on,
but on the other hand
they're a distraction.
Meaning:
they'll maybe
talk to you,
they'll
want answers to questions,
and the whole thing
distracts you.
So maybe make sure
at the launch site
to be the two people,
those who keep calm,
especially when you're not sure
of yourself,
those who can still ignore you a bit.
From the whole launch site
we take our time,
create the calm,
never hectic,
and then
you also get a great launch.
When you're ready
to go for the launch,
one thing is indispensable:
namely that we do a good
pre-launch check.
And the check,
that we've got it,
even if it's never been ingrained yet,
for sure,
is something you already learn there,
it's a really big topic
in the theory,
and you see
everyone doing a kind of stick-and-move.
We catch ourselves through the whole thing,
actually
when the harness is laid out on the ground,
we pick it up,
put it on,
as already shown,
and now
the great control
is,
the reserve handle
is set inside the harness,
are the two split pins
set properly,
the two pins,
do they still go in,
are the pins really set
in.
Just like it is,
the way it should be,
if the handle is somewhere strange,
looks odd in the harness,
something
doesn't fit,
and you can fix that
when you pick up the harness,
by checking the reserve setup first
before putting it on.
And for the 5-point check
the simplest way
is on the body itself,
to start,
we go from the inside
outward,
namely
the reserve having been
already checked,
we then go on
to all the others,
our buckles,
are they closed
and secured.
That includes
the shoulder buckles,
and also includes
the helmet clasp.
What's important is simply
that all the buckles
are closed and secured.
Point 1,
Point 2,
we go further out
from ourselves,
outward,
namely to the risers,
are they not twisted,
do they run
for those lines
going up to the wing.
Wing checked,
in other words,
we've sorted it,
the cells
based on what's needed,
they lie here,
like with the leading edge,
and now we have point 3,
the wing is laid out checked,
meaning,
the way we want it,
is it nicely open
and nicely aligned with the wind.
And point 4
we go to
the wind direction,
and important,
as for strength: nothing
— if we don't have
the right direction,
but a 50-something headwind,
or a 20-something tailwind,
then in terms of strength
it's definitely not right.
And point 5
is the launch strip
and
the area around it is free.
For that,
we check quickly again,
in the air,
yes,
no pilots coming in to land in front of us.
And also the launch strip
really is clear.
Pesky things
like children
or animals
who could suddenly,
during the launch procedure,
run across your launch strip.
If that's the case,
then wait, send people away,
kids out of the way,
wait until the animals have walked past,
the dogs,
the cows grazing,
and only then launch.
Imagine,
if we, with a mass —
let's say,
I'm 80 kg,
with the paraglider
and all the gear,
then I'm at about 100 kg total.
And me,
going at 20 km/h,
is a kinetic energy
that for whoever
I'd hit
becomes very quickly
seriously dangerous.
Important,
if we do a reverse launch,
we've got good wind,
we can do the reverse launch,
then we turn around in the harness
after the 5-point check
to face the wing,
now from points 1 to 4,
nothing changes much,
but what I want to come back to
is namely:
the launch strip,
checking the airspace,
and a free strip,
immediately,
right before the reverse launch,
point 5,
normally,
repeat it again well.
Then we go slowly
into
the launch,
and as I
rightly mentioned,
that is to say,
the three-phase launch.
And it starts with
the inflation phase,
after that comes
the control and correction phase,
and then comes the acceleration phase.
And it's really important
that we think this through in those three steps.
Many pilots,
at the launch site,
are way ahead in their head,
they're already a little airborne,
there's
already the acceleration.
Then we say:
first, do point 1,
do point 2 well,
then inflate,
control and correct,
and then
I decide,
does it fit,
is everything
the way I want,
do I feel safe,
all good,
then comes the acceleration phase.
And you shouldn't do all the three-phase moves at once,
because the control and correction phase
is exactly there
for us to spot a mistake.
The wing is,
for example,
we've got a knot in the line,
we've got something
that's not right,
we abort.
If we're already in the acceleration phase,
already in it,
I wouldn't really do a full abort anymore,
because as we said,
in acceleration
we're moving fast.
And the area
where we ideally want to be airborne quickly,
namely in the air,
because once in the air, we're safer,
we have no obstacles coming at us,
we could trip,
go into the air,
everything fine again.
Important is,
do 1 and 2 well,
and then decide:
yes, well,
is the acceleration good,
or no,
doesn't fit — abort.
By the way,
on a practical exam,
as long as you abort in point 1 or point 2,
that's a perfectly fine abort, no problem.
If you abort in point 3, the acceleration phase,
abort,
then you haven't done point 2 properly,
and then you get a negative point
for the acceleration phase check.
Important is,
afterwards,
when you've
got takeoff speed,
reached it,
and we lift off,
very important,
that after takeoff
we don't let our brakes go.
We keep seeing this in practice,
people on flights
and relatively quickly
want
to get comfortable in the harness,
and good for us but not for the comfort,
but it's dangerous,
the issue,
because we let the brakes go,
and now you suddenly have
a disturbance,
which maybe wasn't noticeable during launch,
or a lot of crosswind,
and the wing relatively quickly
pulls to the side.
And that's plainly connected to the front,
and so,
sit yourself in first,
settle into the harness,
make yourself comfortable first,
when you're far
well into the planned direction,
where your intended flight goes,
have plenty of air and room,
then you can let the brakes go briefly
and get comfortable
and pick the brakes back up afterwards,
in turn.
Now there's also the situation
where right after launch you notice
that we're not flying straight,
but veering right or left.
That can have various causes,
for example,
that already at launch
you weren't in the fall line,
but launched into the wrong direction.
Could be,
that you didn't look forward,
have a knot in the line,
or it could be
that you have strong crosswind,
blowing your tip against the one side.
Most important of all,
that actually in the 3-phase launch
is point 4.
And point 4 is
the proper stabilizing,
that you do.
You've found your direction,
and that has to be the absolute priority.
Regardless of what the cause is,
that you can fly off to the side.
First, weight shift well,
if needed brake on the opposite side
firmly enough,
to fly straight,
to fly far, far,
to get plenty of distance between us and the ground,
and then deal with the problem.
If, if you don't have that,
front or otherwise,
it's pretty hopeless, namely,
that you uncontrolled
head back to the slope,
and depending on the terrain,
obviously not smart,
to land there.
Landing I would not prefer.
I'd always head into open airspace
to fly,
because that gives me time to react.
And that's good,
the bigger the time window,
the more calmly you can address the problem.
And then you have to react accordingly.
Correct is,
when you have a problem,
let's say,
we have a knot in the line,
even though we did our check properly,
and we even
did the 3-phase launch state 2 well,
namely control and correction,
and then we develop a knot in the line
that we didn't see
and now we're flying out there.
Important is: stabilize,
fly straight,
as we've discussed,
and apropos knots in the line.
There's probably no pilot
who hasn't had a knot at some point.
Or that's a bit of a stretch.
It's something
you simply get from this:
because we have loose lines,
and mostly during line sorting at launch,
I have rocks lying around,
or tall grass,
they can form a knot.
It's not tragic,
as long as you know what to do.
Get out into open airspace,
now I start dealing with the problem,
and now let's see, what's the problem?
I recognize, aha,
I actually do have a knot.
When I have the knot,
then I can decide,
do I clear the knot,
there are various aids
to open the knot.
It can be, for example,
that I give a pulse with the brake on the knot side,
in the pulse.
It could be that the knot opens up.
There's the stabilizer line,
in Austrian color,
mostly the trim line,
or the stabilizer line,
or I can also,
for a knot, for example, at the front,
with a collapse,
a 50% collapse,
which we'll get back to later,
if you do that,
I can unload the wing so much
that the chance is high
that the knot opens up again.
When the knot opens,
and you can fly straight from this state,
then you can hold it so that
you fix the weight,
the tip against the brake,
and fly straight,
then we can decide.
And if we can answer the question with 100%:
yes, you can answer it,
then we do it.
Then we go in and land.
But if we're unsure,
then we show,
so, flying straight,
I can show that
you quickly get overwhelmed.
Then it absolutely makes sense,
as long as you've still got steering, over a large field,
ideally not over forest,
to fly to a big meadow,
and then go for the reserve.
Reserve situations we'll cover later.
But we've mentioned it here already.
Dog curves.
Dog curves is also one of those things
you want to avoid,
because they ultimately cost flight time.
And the time,
in other words we end up with less altitude at the point,
if we're heading to a point,
and we just have wind,
then we can simply head straight for it,
and we can keep just as much altitude,
nicely high, as we wanted.
But if we have a wind component from the side, from the left,
and we just fly straight at the point,
then we get a so-called dog curve,
which as we've said in the theory section,
is a big detour,
and then we can reach the point
as we wanted.
That's why we need a wind correction angle.
A wind correction angle is nothing other than
a flight path you choose.
And if we choose a little
into the wind,
then we make a nice straight line toward the point,
and we can reach it optimally.